okay for people who are joining this
livestream we just finished another one
this is a different topic this is
language development of language
language development
and it seems that this is calm day so we
are talking about how to reference
access and do things with columns in
arrays yes so this is an important topic
and users have suggested times right so
I mean we did years ago we had this
concept of band which has been only
somewhat successful yes so the idea here
I think is that alternative to having
multiple column functions we can have a
more powerful symbolic position spec yes
which is what we've kind of already done
with band powerful construction because
it doesn't have to be yes I understand
but it doesn't have to go all the way
across either so one thing that we've
never used is the word slice okay okay
um because I think column is kind of a
shame that that it is I mean maybe
there's a well we already used columns
or something else but but in addition um
okay object on the right hand side right
so at the moment only sparse array
understands band and so of course we
have the many functions that take the
opposition spec
and it will be great if they understood
these or something similar because our
two main instructors are part and
extract so part is effectively
one-dimensional and the symbolic
specification for four part are all and
span which are great will have a similar
symbolic specification of large subsets
of positions for extract yeah I
understand
multi bands okay yeah yeah right which
which has been properly you know moved
across the system okay now we've got the
whole zoo of column functions a lot of
times having these functions or what I
did is just commenting on what they
could do and potential problems they
could have yeah so column I mean yes you
can either have column map as a map at
or as a subset map it's interesting to
see that the two main implementations
are nearly identical so color map is my
bad if experiment and subset map is
experimental which I related both my bad
and subset mad yeah I could play do
different things
follow the same notation for doing
similar things right now we thought that
this notation all comma N which is a
pretty civilized notation for a column
wouldn't you know would work but yet
people still want column you know
because that is a perfectly reasonable
column thing to do I mean we can say
something like um you know we can make
am
some random integer thing of and we can
perfectly well say percent you know all
comma three and we will get that column
now if we want to operate on that column
so one of the issues is we don't have a
good way to say just I mean we're not a
great way to say just map something I
mean if I want to make this for some
reason one does wants to do the row
mapping so one possibility is we take
this and we want to return something
like this okay
whatever that means that's like a subset
map onto that onto that set of things
right I would think so that's fine well
so so I don't understand why I can't do
so what you're saying is if I say map at
F blah blah blah um I see the problem
here is no I mean what's wrong with this
yeah now for somebody someone doesn't
think of doing this but it's certainly
easy to do okay so you're saying the
other case of this which won't I don't
know what this will do actually I mean
if I say subset map of this it really
wants to check in advance that it
returns list which is the right thing
yeah if you try now accumulate that
gives a list from a list
I'll reverse or something yeah actually
that's a better version of that would be
sort so that's perfectly still
functionality by the way we should give
some examples of subset map doing this
and it's documentation um do we have a
good place to put here our column
functions oh my gosh we've already had
discussion of column functions how long
ago is our discussion of column
functions I don't even want to look okay
okay so let's keep going down here
linear combination of columns oh my gosh
how do you do that and all the
operations of you know Gaussian
elimination or something right so the
can do that because not look at several
columns at the same time right so this
would require a generalization of
subsets math query can do that but
that's highly non-trivial what else
query do on an array effectively as if
it was acting on the data set of that
array
we should look at query more seriously
because I don't think it's been yeah
property work through um okay yeah so
this is this is extensions yeah so here
I'm I'm trying to create a slice which
will be these symbolic specification of
position specs we said two particular
cases which I'm calling lower case wrong
now what is just for example okay but
but in in reality this so it still was
real matrix define matrix is here okay
so this is equivalent if I'm not
mistaken to extract a matrix all comma
three
just a simple addition well almost
anything we put in there is going to be
longer than all comma three unless we
had a notation I mean unless we had a
special character type notation for the
thing like a prefix form so I mean
possibility that what would happen okay
imagine there was a thing called column
slice or something or even I mean
imagine we had a prefix form okay boy
what would it be
um I don't know let's say it was I'm
trying to figure something it isn't that
big yours here
okay semicolon : okay this is a little
bit obscure but let's say it was that
let me call on : 4 okay and that means
so that's then equivalent to a slice of
let's say well actually there might be
an easier way to do this I mean so I
don't understand why slice because what
we could also do is to say that slice of
4 by default defaults to a column slice
but that's equivalent to slice all comma
4 I'm saying yes because it's kind of
pointless on the first so let's just
understand if we had that kind of
notation so we can we could define this
here I know what your slice what is your
slice here do it's a more complicated
construction that is able to move with
your fruits but so perhaps the
definition you want is the wrong call
yeah okay so let's call that let's call
it lowercase slice I mean I don't know
where where is that I see what does that
mean what is what is the definition of
your slicer
I think that's just a sparse array
version of yeah that's just saying
that's just the equivalent I would think
of saying all comma ns yes yes it's it's
substracting elements from the second
column so I mean in the in this
situation what we're doing is slice of
level arrow um index right alternatively
one could imagine a slice of index 1 and
x2 la blah blah right which is very much
equivalent to the standard parts back so
this is equivalent to a part spec that
is the kind of a one hot part spec where
only the level so that's equivalent to a
part spec which is sparse array of level
arrow index and whatever the depth is
well except and the default is all yes
yes there have been some comments that
sometimes in deep data sets you have to
write many oh ok
okay so this is again equivalent to all
all - what is this that says at level 3
you have elements 2 & 3 level 2 you have
element 1 and we have a notation
for that in extract we do that would
just be an extract of all comma 1 comma
2 3 you wouldn't it yes so all comma
this comma this right has another level
of base bracket no what is that that's
something different
same elements but are not flattened okay
so let's loop back to what we were
originally talking about here which is
the question of what column operations
you want to do so this column map thing
says apply this operation so I mean
right now we already have map hat of let
me define some array here let's do this
I have that definition okay
so map hat of F comma matrix comma all
comma two will map that onto column two
okay now I mean
trouble is what's happening here um I
mean really this isn't very hard to do
map at all comma - it's just a little
bit obscure to read and arguably you
know that should turn into I mean we
should just have a utility function for
some of these that just say column map
because because you know the difficulty
of this is not that it's a lot to type
it isn't it's the people don't
conceptually understand what's going on
I mean there's really no typing problem
here okay so my suggestion here is that
rather than having multiple column
functions if we had a powerful language
for symbolic position specs but how does
color insert work right now doesn't
really in that I don't even know I don't
think it does I don't think insert I
think insert is a very simple function
right insert and delete unfortunately do
not work well with two so I think I have
an example in the delete with insert is
that is going to insert always the same
element we cannot insert different
elements so that's why this little
prototype uses transpose instead well
what would happen if we supported in
insert and all for one of the ijk so
the three stains enter matrix list a B
all comma two this is equivalent to 1
comma 2 2 comma 2 3 comma 2 and then
inserting a be in all those places
sorry surrogate that's equivalent what
change Paul comma 2 to the list 1 comma
2 comma 2 3 comma 2 3 positions because
that's that you see it's inserting the
list because that's how insert is
defined that even if you specify
multiple positions it will insert the
same thing well it's really what it
needs is a subset insert this is the
same as you sort of has the map su the
difference.we maps map at and subsets
map is it yes so this is one of this
cases in which we have two rules we
could say 1 comma 2 goes to a 2 comment
towards to be ok so in other words if
you say if we have an insert like we do
with replace part if we say insert and
then we could say something like all
comma 2 goes to ABC potentially that's
interesting 5 replace part also had this
multi-argument form oh yeah absolutely
that's right but in certainty that's
correct we didn't think of that
but it's a good idea it's a really good
idea what would happen ok so that's the
story for insert what about delete
doesn't okay because it can be expanded
so for example in the same examples you
have if you evaluate this it will
complain but if you change it by the
least 1 comma 2 comma 2 3 comma 2 fine
so it could work I think this is really
interesting I think this is a really
good idea which had never thought of the
Flies unbelievable in 30 years we never
thought of that but anyway this big
space um so there are a few places in
which we support the position spec
function and the Ultima 2 notation is
supported in some of them so what
something we could start with the
supporting systematically yeah I agree I
mean an insert this is particularly
interesting ok so you know
I'm trying to think I mean the only
problem with map out of all comer to the
good news about this is it's very clear
the F is going to be applied to each
element now I'm you know subset map is a
little bit of a weird name for well it's
not that weird actually no I think it's
a good it's a month it is understood not
fun function there for me no I agree
that's magnificent
that's quite magnificent because that
map takes general position specs we
could have a list of individual
positions yeah no I understand or it
could be a band band is so far I mean it
could be supported so far it's only
supported by sponsoring yeah
get it but I mean band could be okay
Karl is asking um about inserting a
column that is for example some of
another of two other columns that's a
good question I mean the way that we
would have to do it is it would end up
looking like but that would be sort of a
generalization of subset map I mean you
know the one way to do is obviously
insert matrix you know all come to arrow
matrix all comma three plus matrix all
comma four okay this is some kind of
generalized subset map we could imagine
a rule third argument for subset map or
do we not even need that
okay so much like these other things we
could imagine somehow combining those
with rules I think they'd seen the first
time in or the third first you mean
second argument no think about the first
in the sense of a function that does
something and another function that
because the addition is going to be
performed by the first function but if
first segment um
Sandra on our live stream is pointing
out the analogy with take list quite got
that
at some yeah call is pointing out that
he takes some that's a thing causes he
uses for combining that long coordinates
into position
what does that do what is the hash pause
arrow do
but it's inserting multiple different
elements xander points out could be
called and could be insert list as take
list is successively taking okay that's
interesting but but I think that the
problem is right so we have in general
you're picking up end things and you're
putting end things in oh I see I see I
see the problem is doesn't insert
already take multiple allow you to do
multiple insertion I thought it did this
replace part which has a similar
situation this annotation in which you
can insert the same so replace the same
element they are called okay this makes
more sense to me okay go ahead sorry
you're saying yes I just need to compare
the page of insert with the pitcher for
a spot okay
so here we have a way of actually hold
the fort for just a minute I have to be
right back
okay god yes story lines of replaced
part you see the two cases on the fifth
one is replace many parts with the same
element and the previous one is replace
each part with a different element
mm-hmm so I think that that flexibility
is what we are missing an insert okay so
let's take a look at that so this is
saying right and insert we don't have
any rule syntax and we have to replace
all those positions by this we insert
the same element right so okay so I'd
say we have same element insertion would
be insert into our matrix all come a to
arrow acts for instance right now what
we want which we don't have a convenient
way to do no actually what does this
mean does this mean see that there's
things we could have here we could have
this we could have some lists like that
make sense because we know we want to
put at least how does it work and
replace part well we have to thread in
in the best part there is no ultimate to
notation so that's the difference with
band in band it doesn't stand that if
you place our list on the right then
that means a list it even works with
matrices that it inserts them hello
environment so to speak okay so you're
saying with replaced part there's no way
to have kind of parametrized replacement
I mean the only parametrize thing we
have is like map index which is very
low-level parameterization because the
typical thing you want okay is replace a
column for example okay so how do you
replace a column you would have to say
see if it is the second column you would
have to say one two goes to a goes to B
alright so that and that is again an
example of a bad story
so the main problem is that in this
there's no auto threading right because
the natural thing is to expand all comma
two in the same place where it is to the
list 1 2 2 2 3 2 and then all those
elements will be replaced by the same so
I mean you know I hate to point this out
but if we had something this might be
very very obscure we had something more
like that
no not flatten out what am I talking
about um what is the thing that we have
where with the auto flag now because
it's going to start by putting each of
these flattened in elements at each
place yeah I don't think it's quite
right but what I'm saying is some
right-hand side I see something that
forces Otto distribution because that
will be the same thing you know here
okay in this
face that will just generate an error
won't it because it'll be the wrong
shape that could be interpreted if you
change the ultimate tool by the list
above actually I see I see
insert the same app amounted every
position so far everywhere where we have
where we have meet augment to its full
equivalent to replacing automata - list
ok what we want here
we need this to splice because it's ok
so what would this look like with band
step so it would be like 1 2 3 2 1
it's so freeing grotesque so that's the
first time in the last element under
under but there might be an alighted
syntax for band sorry I think it's it
means yes ok so let's look at so that is
sort of an existence proof that we can
represent ok here's a crazy idea what if
instead of all we were to say automatic
comma - or some other word that means
it's not completely stupid word because
that's basically saying ok let's look at
that I'm gonna case you'll replace part
ok
so there's a problem alright so we go
automatic XYZ okay now then hit the
problem problem I mean if we said
automatic automatic well it's not clear
that does the wrong thing I mean because
we cristela matrix that it could be a
bit complicated if we mix them why is
that so complicated that means okay so
what would that mean that would meet
lips what the heck did I just do there
help um automatic comma all yeah there's
no problem with that
that what that would do is you'd say X Y
and that would take the X for the first
column the Y for the second column
repeat them this is interesting let's
look at some other cases okay well what
else do we need okay so let's look at
delete
I don't think delete is problematic I
think delete is quite easy yes I think
that might be problematic with delete is
that if we say for example delete all
the elements of the second row do we
leave the community room deleting all
the elements of a row is it equivalent
to eat in the room leaving that row
empty now it's equivalent to deleting
the row we have no representation of an
empty row I mean isn't that
in in um well we could wait to see that
right now I mean if we delete if we have
ABCD well actually let's do this a b c
okay now we say delete element two one
right how I see so of course we could
say here delete element 2 and that
deletes the whole row but when we go to
all I'm not sure which one is because
this under thing is all is the list of
all elements well then we got the same
deal with automatic vs. all I don't
think automatic is so bad I think it
just means it's an automatic index not
the whole thing it's it's threading over
the whole thing
yeah Carla suggesting full as an
alternative to something we could
consider look I think the concept of
symbolic in this has a meaning in
extract sure I mean the bowling ban is
fine it's a bunch of work I think this
is more valuable this rectilinear stuff
is more valuable but ok ok so let's look
at
other things so the linear combinations
of columns business okay so I claim um
and see what that would look like what
would that look like that would be
something like this automatic to arrow
matrix all comma 2 plus matrix all comma
3 that's what that would be
now is there alternatively a you know a
subset map generalization way of doing
that I bet there is because I think what
it is there if we allow automatic in
subset map I reckon we can do this ok
maybe I don't completely see how to do
this it would have to be a list of lists
in there in there in the last argument
so somehow in subset map we pass to the
function in the first argument a list of
elements so what we need now is to pass
two lists of elements right so that we
add them and it still returns a single
list of elements right right right right
right right right so it was something
like this it will be this and then it
would be all comma three I'm just making
up what these are but all come a5 or
something right so it would be in the
second argument and then we would need
perhaps all three or five goes to alter
so what do we take we put which so far
is the same thing I see we're putting it
in the same place okay so this will be
the where it gets put okay so the
minimal case of this would be I mean
right now we've got subset
of accumulate ABCD 2 3 say 2 3 4 ok
actually let's say ok well this could be
something like that which would mean
overwrite the elements at positions 1
for 2 with the results of applying that
thing 2/4 for 2 3 ok so then the multi
form of that is not too difficult to
understand I think I'm in the multi form
which are now the we would have to
decide and probably it's more convenient
to have the first argument be um I mean
we might have to say to get it the
question is is it passed us a list or
not whether we have to say apply + um
onto these things which perhaps for
consistency we would have to do so then
then this will become as it's a matrix
here and then this would be
list let's say to all yeah
comma three all no no no I meant all to
you know arrow and then that goes
actually I I really want I think that
has to go to automatic for for example
is that right
I think it's understand yeah probably so
yeah call is asking we're at subset
apply we might get there depends how
common this all is yeah now we couldn't
do
could we do turtle because that will be
passed oh yeah that's right
yeah yeah that's right yeah right right
okay um now these we can replace cannot
insert but if you want to insert a
column use insert right if you want to
get
three columns and add I mean then you'd
have to have a mixture of inserts and
deletes I think yes right well you're
saying could subset map I don't think
that's a reasonable thing to do because
do something yes if you just want to do
something use map hat
if you just want to do something to a
column but depends what do you want to
do at element-wise to a column if you
want to do it to the whole column use
subset map if you want to insert to
something use insert now I mean a
question is can we get a simpler syntax
for band that does the useful thing like
for example disband of an integer might
mean a column because band of a single
integer doesn't mean anything right now
okay so this is not a discussion of band
things yeah it's possible to but could
band of n mean column n doesn't seem
obviously stupid to say that well
promises that the first definition of
mind so it would be a bit strange if we
now change that no it's not vertical and
the first definition of band there is a
list understand it starts with zero zero
for example no 1 1 and then goes
diagonally sure now the question is
whether band of 1 or band of two could
be equivalent to band of this would be
um one two
- 1 2 0 1 I know it doesn't I mean it's
a little weird I don't think it's
particularly weird cuz the other case
isn't very useful
I mean band of one isn't very useful
here yes but it's a bit strange if bang
of 2 is different from band of 1 -
because they are starting at the same
place so bang :
I think would be easier to read and it
will be equivalent to band 1 comma 2 :
um Carla's saying he finds it crazy the
band is diagonal yeah band was a
function introduced I mean it's to do
with you know it's like finding
tridiagonal matrices and things don't we
do we have a thing um AB stir
what about having a column and row band
and then this can have all the fragments
step it's possible
the reason : loves to miss arresting
column of three sadly we already used
column for a not totally stupid thing
of course it's a form of what that yeah
yeah yeah right um well look the
question of whether we have yeah I'm
trying to think is there another thing
other than band that we could use here
you know column parts or something I
like it very much
yeah either slice or column slice I
still support the idea of slice
defaulting to a column because then it
can easily be generalized what's that no
I understand so I mean band is diagonal
slice is rectilinear so to speak so then
slice of n would typically be equivalent
to something like um n come automatic
comma n right long
from sander here let's see a mixture of
insert and map apply would be
interesting so you want to add a column
to a matrix that is the sum of two other
columns yeah I mean the question is
whether insert I mean what you're
talking about there is some kind of map
insert type thing or insert map
um we're basically what's happening is
well no I think you're right insert
apply might be the correct form so that
we have in our matrix
oh boy what does this do
so wait a met no actually this is oh boy
I'm getting my brain tangled here what
this is doing okay so insert apply so
the general case is take various quotes
slices apply an operation to them yeah
and insert the results somewhere okay so
whereas insert would require you to so
the question is it's it's an insert what
is it is it a map and know what it is
it's something like map at insert is
that right where it says okay so the
first thing is an F a matrix and then
where from and where to I think so this
is very similar then to this except map
extension we were thinking about in
which the last two arguments are
connected by
only difference here is that this is an
insert version of subset map right well
I mean we could imagine a subset map
insert it might be the better name for
it because it is exactly doing a subset
map although to be fair the insertion
doesn't have to necessarily be
conforming whereas a subset map it does
have to be conforming well the insert no
no I'm wrong
if it's not at the top level a row right
we could just insert X as the fifth row
right
okay so subset map insert so let's just
take a look at what this would look like
in a real case okay so subset map insert
let's say we're going to put the total
of two rows matrix here and then it
would say um no no this isn't quite
right this isn't quite right I mean we
could say slice two with the
presentation what you seen was all gamma
2 gamma 3 that means insert at the
second position Isis
so this would just be okay slice to come
a slice three gosh I can't type this
word arrow slice five and the only
difference is that really the other one
is short for subset map replace which is
really the same which is subset map
itself because map is by default a
replacer why isn't this called subset
insert no because it has a map operation
and this is a similar discussion had
with subset map in which we were
discussing whether it's Mora map
function or at replace functions yes
it's both instance
um but I think this is an interesting
function subset map insert but then ok
so then this map corresponds to insert
so a pure insert let's look at insert
for a second ok so insert in a matrix
slice to arrow ABC that is equivalent to
insert of automatic comma to ABC correct
um ok and delete matrix comma slice 3
it's pretty clean
I mean that's pretty that's pretty clear
I mean you know that's pretty reasonable
which is the equivalent of delete matrix
of automatic comma 3 or full comma 3 or
no it wouldn't no it wouldn't
Oh women wait a minute would it work
the but the case the row case wouldn't
work ok ok ok ok fair enough
this would work with all as well but a
row might would with all would end up
with a null list
okay what other functions are there in
our collection of column Abul functions
well so column part the obvious thing to
do would be matrix of sliced two right
giving the column in part two notation
the first thing you provide is always
about the rows so we would be breaking
this could have consequences
okay so that's a question mark question
mark question mark I mean do we agree
that extract
yes because what we are discussing here
our position specs not about the specs
okay so the functions that take position
specs are the ones we discussed delete
insert replace part extract and subset
math that wool really I find that hard
to believe we have so many with position
specs there aren't
what about things like what what about
map out so that we don't you should we
should expect to work yes well we've
been reserving slice all these years so
maybe we'll finally get to use it
are you sure things like mean there's a
lot of things that have level specs I'm
seeing now flatten it but not this one
but we'll have more ad functions okay so
again its insert delete flattened art
very well what would flatten out to just
specify a position at which effectively
flatten is being mapped I think that's
pretty funky I mean flattening is is
structure modifying I don't really
believe in that one well perhaps a weird
thing but the point is that the third no
the second argument of flatten art is a
position strike it takes a list of
positions what
of things take less suppositions don't
they that's what I'm saying maybe
missing some but very few we have gone
just a few times that's crazy
so Sandra is asking about this partition
that
takes me a moment to read this these
wooden served yes is inserts the yeah
yeah that's right it inserts the total
of every row what's not the total of
every it's a total of that the elements
two and three of every row isn't slice
of to sequence all comma two so sander
it's not sequence it's in most places it
will be a list automatic comma to I
think it's talking about the party specs
the problem is that of course we are
converting one element into a sequence
of two and that's going to confuse all
parts tax yeah I understand
okay listen we should probably wrap up
um there's some very good ideas here I'm
very pleased with this very very pleased
I mean this has been a long this is a
chestnut that's been you know hardening
in the Sun for years um I think this is
great I think we are actually on track
to solve this finally okay we got it
it's you know we're gonna we're not
gonna do it today but we're on a roll
let's go solve some other old chestnuts
we've got I've got a list of old
chestnuts I think we're we're gonna do
exception soon too and package layout
which is actually on its way to get in
solved but this column thing so let's
work through this but I'm really pretty
pretty excited about this this looks
really really promising to me I think we
should work through the automatic calm
or whatever and equivalently the slice
whatever I mean we haven't talked about
what a multi argument slice does and
we've got a lot of freedom than what
that does
for example I think I think your idea of
the of the d-dimensional slice you know
level arrow index is perfectly good and
that would mean that would mean the
hyperplane you know hyperplane in the
array correct I was just saying so in
other words I could say I mean I could
also say so what would it mean if I did
slice 3/5 okay so in other words what
that means is if I were to do this okay
let's let's do the following let's say I
said delete in a matrix slice 3/5 that
would delete so so for example this
actually is a useful thing right i mean
i could say delete up to column 3
through 5 seems quite useful to me
exactly exactly that's equivalent to
slice of to arrow this right I agree by
the way what would this do with
associations or a data set for example
and we should be able to say data set we
should be able to do something like this
delete data set matrix absolutely okay
for example slice header and that should
delete the column if this is a list of
associations that should delete
the elements of each association with
that header but then we would be working
at the first level no we're not matrix
is a list of associations exactly right
which is the typical data set but that
is a column header this is really great
this is gonna really work well we should
have solved this years ago it's a pretty
simple solution actually I mean and then
then if you want to get I guess a call
is saying no senators saying hyper plane
or hyper volume um what do we mean
actually by that so no he's right what
it means is we are constraining the
index for level n right but we are
constraining no other indices right okay
but but so in this case just for one
second the multi argument slice would
potentially be so let's take the example
of a data set where I think that's a
more realistic things so this so let's
imagine the planet's data set for
example um
then let's say we want to delete the
thing to decide is whether even have to
hearth we mean act on the initial data
set or the second one yeah I think we
have to there's something to understand
here also with respect to how data set
itself works and how because within data
set you know we might have a data set
and we should obviously be able to say
slice header and that should be
equivalent to data set of all yeah all
comma header right you what oh I see
what you're saying well we where we say
slice of two of the matrix a Zachary
like thing is extract matrix slice -
yeah that's nice sander is commenting
that the term slice is already used in
the context of image 3d slices where it
always extracts planes 2d planes not
hyper volumes I'm not busy
this very well I mean when we say what
would it mean to have if we only give
one index if we say level arrow index I
don't understand how we could ever
extract anything other than what Sandra
is calling a hypervolume because we're
not constraining the other indices yes
yes this this object the object defined
by a single slice specification I mean
you know for example this if we slice
lev one arrow IND one left to arrow into
that could potentially be a co dimension
to object I think we do if we want to
think about currying I mean I don't know
how much currying does I'm now confused
by something just part curry doesn't
know it doesn't curry but extract does
curry doesn't it actually that's a bad
test okay um
comment on the live streamers wanna
comment on I'm late for something else
here which was a thing about inserting
comments right a suggestion from nickel
or about insert comment of garnet
problem position the reason we can't do
that is because comment just doesn't
appear in the in the expression
you'd have to insert the comment in an
abstract syntax tree of the expression
rather than the expression itself
because by definition if I say comment
hello
and if I say comment hello times you
know two plus three I just get two plus
three and if I were to say comment there
plus three oh for goodness sake I don't
get a syntax error because but if I said
x three I'd go syntax error
alright I for some reason I'm less I am
I feel yeah right this is actually very
exciting we've solved some problems here
I think that have been around for
decades so that is that's exciting for
some reason my day is such that I'm not
expressing exuberance as much as I might
um but this is really good and thank you
everybody here and people on the
livestream very helpful and Jose I think
we should just you know we should pursue
this try and try and sort it out right
sounds good okay see y'all soon